hey I'm Omer I'm the founder and CEO of
any do any do is the world's leading
task management application for mobile
devices our mission is to turn every day
into a good day through creation of
day-to-day simple beautiful and fun life
management applications creating an app
is not just having an icon and the
user's home screen it's about creating
engagement and getting the user to use
your app from different parts of the OS
that's why we integrated our self our
apt deeply to the OS and create a
different ways for the user to interact
with our app in most cases people think
about opening in app just through the
icon but in any dudes case we've deeply
integrated into the OS in several ways
the first way was to integrate with
widgets in the widgets you can actually
see all of your tasks they have planned
for today tomorrow upcoming and some day
but you can even mark them as complete
so just by clicking on one of the tasks
you can choose and you can mark them as
complete the second type of integration
that we did in the active part was to
actually in the Notification Center show
all the task that they have planned for
today and you can easily scroll between
everything you have planned or add a new
task we've seen that over forty percent
of our users open the app not through
the icon which means that the
integration with iOS on the deepest
level provides a lot more engagement
than anything else so to sum up the
Android platform allows us to do a lot
of things in order to increase users
engagement we've managed to create an
experience in which the app is so deeply
integrated to the to the device where
those feel as if it's part of the OS
this allows us to create a great user
interface a great experience and a
better usage from our users Thank You
Android